Well for. G m b. In double the bomb. To sit on a double s. Double to. Well our first time here. More names bob.
To sit and. Our first kind then been about six weeks before the aquarius festival. With two close friends.
And we were coming up. To help get the sart organized.
And we were driven by the idea that the incredible string band were going to be plying which they never did.
For the six weeks proud of the first of all.
My mind job was working in the cafe which was cooking breakfast lunch and dinner for the workers. If you're a worker.
Putting together the sot you're paid. One nym back and one nym back.
Was enough to boil your breakfast lunch and dinner.
Which usually consisted of porridge for breakfast and fried vegetables for than a lot of veggies
and rice is a very macrobiotic time. At the same time or unfortunately.
He was apprehended for the cultivation of marijuana.
Which resulted in all the other people who were working on the festival so at putting on a benefit concert.
To try to rise the biles of our to get out of this we had to spend the week in the is more lockout waiting for the
night just right because i only had one daya week.
And we got busted on a sign di that i had caught so we had a white tool following week to get to see him.
And we had a wonderful benefit dance. When my money but if we had a wonderful time on. Yes. So after that.
I went to sydney for a few months following that. To earn the money to cover the buy a little friend.
And then came back up and rented another. Farmhouse over on stone issued road. Where i lived for six months. With.
Maybe six other people in the big old house. At that time. Nimbin jihad jane.
Purchased by the original group of people who got it together. And there was still.
Shares for syle so i promptly went back off to sydney to work to earn enough money to.
Which i did and arrived back up here. In my nineteen seventy seven. My memories of the first of all.
I think my strongest memory of the festival was the visual impression of it. When you look.
From the main street of newman. Down into the paddocks that are behind the hotel and it looked like me.
Camped out for the not in some media evil. Battle there were hundreds of little camp followers everywhere.
There was missed. It was in the middle of winter. Heavy mist.
So you could just see these glow of the force of the smoke in the mist camborne so that you.
When you're actually in the solitary in the camping area. Of an evening.
You couldn't say more than fifteen twenty feet in front of you.
Which was really rather exciting when you're walking around you sort of bump into all these rather interesting and.
Amazing people are remember the. The public access star age. In particular to in terms of.
If you want to get on stage
and do something in front of a whole lot of other people you just had to write your name down on eye on the sheer jewel.
On a blank spot and. There was lots of other people in the city as well. A lot of rhythm. A lot of drumming. People.
Of bongos and logs and anything you could shake from it still goes on to die i was in town
and the us that are in the african dance group had the whole of just ramping with this constant rhythm it was wonderful.
A lot of religious groups. At the first of all i mean the christians were perhaps the most visible.
I had a really large market. But there were maybe half a dozen different religious organizations set up the tent city.
Cloyd the spiritual tried. The hari tent. Well. There was a free feast every lunch time. If you were hungry.
Very much into their watts. Sugar sweets lots of. Very sweet food on like a sugar. But anyway.
If you were hungry you could go along they always get a meal. They had a twenty four hour chanting session.
On buddha's birthday which was on the full moon in taurus. It was.
Celebration of the buddha and they chanted from midnight to midnight. Without so this is always somebody working at it.
And a lot of people during that twenty first would go and join in and chant perhaps an hour.
We'll conserve into a frenzy. Get hungry and mostly off somewhere else. I think for a lot of people through the.
One of the great things i had to come to grips with was a toilet situation.
Which was a circle of perhaps four four foot high. They had a whole circle inside of it. Of dani's.
And when you went in you said madonna you were fighting perhaps seven
or right other people who were also sitting on their. Dunnies.
I think it's small
and you can chat with a little petition between your downing the next danny was quite a social plies the role of
danny's.
Not quite as social as a sourness of course which were very social very social
and there was too soon as there was one that was built out of corrugated on and.
People got burned bums in that one because it used to get really crowded
and i just what it is pack in there with all these sweaty nike ad bodies everywhere.
And the other one was built over a creek.
And you could jump through a hole in the floor into the creek when your heart in a lot of street activity.
All the time. A lot of the shops at that time in women were. Unused. Just empty shops.
But during the festival all these people came out of the woodwork and set up things like a banana fruit
or shops in just empty shop fronts and things are for a lot of street theater. Especially in the evening.
Mostly things are street theater happening. And then of course there was the great drama of the bust.
When the police arrested somebody. Couple people i think that was down in the. Camping area.
Supposedly for one position. But by the time they got them from the camps or.
Up to the street with a paddy wagon was there must have been at least three hundred people had surrounded the paddy
wagon. The handcuffs were actually cut off with bolt cutters and the goa sky and a policeman had his gun stolen.
Now the result of the gun being stolen was that the next morning there would have been perhaps fifty. Down all.
Very heavy very serious and want to know where the gun was and.
Apparently it was returned i don't know who turned it over who'd even taken it but it was.
It was returned and even the escapade he returned as well. With a lawyer boy saw it and everything.
Come down considerably after that. What else was. All i was actually living. About ten kilometers. Out of town.
At the time was to travel in early every morning light up. Open up the kitchen and get the. Porridge hot.
Things like to get the porridge out renting a farmhouse. Far dollars a week. I think or pine and.
When we arrived we had about eighty dollars to and i'm so we immediately. Spent fifty on advance rent.
This and make sure that we wouldn't run out of that it was just to get. Sorry. What brought me to the festival.
Was i desire to get out into the country. It had been. I suppose part of the alternative thoughts.
At that time that the end result was to leave the city to get back to ny to go to the country to grow your own
vegetables to build your own house. Just to do it you know.
And i had tried once before very briefly in kangaroo valley and that had been a complete failure.
Scuttled back to sydney. After only a few weeks of there. Wondering how i'd cope with leeches in the future.
And this was just. This was.
It was just to be in the area i'd lived at mullumbimby for a wall
and there's a lot of people coming out in him than i'm a kind of an imminent. Lot of talk of.
Let's settle here and things like that which is pretty much what i did eventually.
Yes i think that will mean that it was.
It was just to be at the gathering of the clans it felt like all of your brothers and sisters were coming along and.
That was where you should be nimby n.g.'s well. I don't know what name binjie means i'm sorry in the earth spirit.
I don't know off the word name down. And the name being i've heard a lot of the cars and. Explanations for the nine.
At the time of the festival. The providing thought was that a name than was like an aboriginal. Wise man a holy man.
And it's a spirit. Or sorts as well. Apparently the area wasn't was never actually lived in.
Bar the reason i came here for the the men and the boys came here for and purposes or for religious ceremonies.
And then they went back to wherever i lived i think they probably live close to the coast where there was more fishing.
Because that the bundjalung people who were the productive dominant drive of the area were very much into their fishing.
Coastal by strong. I mean they started at the bundjalung when the. All grandmother and her sons.
Arrived at the beach at. Evans head there and. I think grandmother.
One of her sons fell asleep in the eye and the other ones.
Went off looking for food somewhere else and dawud and i camped there on the hill. At evan's hidden started off.
So what exactly it means i'm not sure.
Except that it probably has a lot to do with with something reasonably cycloid to every ginny's the nine itself an
injury was spilt like that. I suspect. Just to give people a lot of trouble in zion. The property. Was bored.
Probably about six months after the festival probably took that long to get enough people together with enough finance.
To purchase it i think it was found before that there was quite a land depression and probably it was a silent
and a to mine for syle. For quite some time.
The ardea of this particular property and borrowing it and getting a community.
Happening here it was the brainchild of mangal braugher and joyce and the woman who was luminous through line.
And brian. Came out looked at the price. Took one look at and said yes this is the place for me.
And gathered together as many friends and friends of friends and. It was bought. I wasn't one of the original.
Forty six people i came in probably at number four you know on. Thing. When a couple of other people had sold out and.
Well it's hard as i'll.
Braun's are those i've done i've drawn dollar deals coincided with everybody else others i probably didn't because he's
gone. But his concept was a community of people that live together very closely. A lot of. Close. Intense.
Into personal reactions very much the encounter group thought situation you know. You're feeling she to use i.
You give me the shits that i just why you're looking. Whatever. It's not for wall be very difficult why to leave.
Permanently and i think he felt that that was our deals have been sacrificed.
To other more pressing things like shelter. And water and the people was spreading people building houses.
Separated a wife from the community hassen. Went being seen the dies at a time and things like that.
He never bothered with the house he just moved into the old the area that was here.
And lived there and wasn't interested in anything agricultural law. Or other wars.
He was definitely a people person and. He went back to the city and. Started a circus.
In terms of water in what i read. Originally were sharing everything. Originally. All food was bought.
Just as a big bulk shop. The a community house there was a large pantries now the office. Funny how things change.
Where the falling cabinet is now there used to be big. Bins full of grinds and.
There was an attitude then of trying to be agricultural self-sufficient. That's never really have enjoyed it.
The soils not growing.
And the people who were coming live here weren't really destined to be farmers advancing with one of them a very people
oriented as will.
Because social interactions always been a very large part of this community aspect of most communities too
when you're living in sharing a lot of the. Bill these are people. It industry them and talk to them. Whatever.
For them. It's been a very very sort of organic process. Once again primarily to do with.
Who was here at any given time and. The top of person they were with a dominant top or personality who had very strong.
Or ideas and attitudes and they want to do particular things. Mother divided you know.
I think if you've got people that are very motivated to do a particular thing
and can express their ideas well then the other people who perhaps on some out of out of can think well that's the
that's a good way to go to strike that mine and mine only one of the big things is everyone. Building houses.
Obviously getting. Individual shelter. Situation especially as more and more people start having families and.
When the people first bought the property. There was no children involved. One of the shareholders was pregnant and.
She had her child he wanted probably up in the community. And since then there's been i think.
Fifteen children born in the probably year as people tended to have families perhaps.
Break up into more traditional nuclear family situations like built himself. Nuclear family storehouses.
In various spots around the property there's no one as yet has actually sort of built a group. Top of living situation.
I've gotten a number of.
For example single people building a place together and and sharing in our person want to see more of that. But.
Well i haven't got the war from the two children. Everything. According to the statistics. One dog. Yes.
It has it has because it has been a bush experience of the nuclear family but not totally.
Has it been a bush experience of the nuclear family in some respects yes it has. I mean i've got a house.
And we've got a vegie garden next to the house. But there's a large community.
Vegetable garden happening as well that a lot of the.
Single people who are here what has been a bit of a population shift. Of light. A number of the.
All the people have all the shareholders.
But with more regional shareholders perhaps only regional shareholder rather than all that will put me down.
I just like that. Have moved to lose more education actually had a lot to do with that. There's no final.
He is living on twelve in that the nearest hospitals if you've got children that are going on to year eleven
and twelve is in lismore it's obviously a damn sight easier to go to hospital is more he living in his mother rather
than travel. Sixty or seventy eight. On a bus. So that's been a factor.
I consider other factors too just wishing for more. Critique on foot perhaps or.
Wanting to have a job that requires you doing. Working in lismore or. Every day.
Is not the most convenient place to travel to and from on a regular basis at hand and they can be done.
Just a lot of wear and tear on a vehicle. The nuclear family. In the bush.
This still a lot of facilities a shared for example.
Most people still do all the washing in the community laundry a couple of pumping systems that provide water to the
whole community.
And
when you know that for example if the pump breaks down even though all martin be the one is using that particular pump
i'm up at one of the guys down fixes and more problems i always fixing the problem.
But i do fix the family and i get all the washing machines and things like that. So. And then in terms of.
The the normal. For example. Bills and debts that.
A nuclear family living alone in on their own piece of land would incur that's that something that i haven't had to
live with for example you know the rights and. Land texas for example. All that sort of stuff. That's part of just.
Everyone pays a certain amount to the cooperative. Every year and that covers all laws. Talks of bills.
Sharing certain things yes and having your own.
As will definitely be in financial benefit i mean i couldn't have been unemployed for a good many.
And i certainly couldn't of a career out of this law for almost from a self.
Unless i could have shared with other people. I suppose it was never a stated goal. Originally.
But i suppose everybody. Would have lot of would have had that. That concept did. To to be able to somehow be.
Become economically independent. And live this lifestyle.
Is just phoning the whys of doing it you know while still looking as a.
Not really not in this particular community i mean other communities by that i think have perhaps more of a group
consciousness towards. Finance rising and. Economic viability perhaps in us. It's women communities a.
Really just a product of the sum total of the people who happen to have them and specially with.
Not so much tunnel because it's a lie. And it drew from such a large.
Sort of data bias will put some bias when it originally set up it's got. Factions of all stripes sauces and colors.
But a number of the other all the communities. Probably was started. Primarily from a group of known friends.
And known friends are usually people with similar ideas and attitudes
and aspirations to usually get within certain boundaries of us and as a very middle class community.
With a lot of people coming from. Generally middle class. Taught backgrounds and. Probably lots of us holding.
Lots of middle class as an idea is the end of the day.
I mean i know the community i've been back as wildly almost every shareholder's a schoolteacher and.
They're very educationally involved. Fantastic fantastic. I can't think of a bit applies.
In terms of some way to bring up one's children. I really can't think of i better place in terms of having.
Having an informant where your children can not come home as a sara lee from the school bus in the afternoon you won't
see them till dark.
And you're not in the slightest bit worried as to where they've gone that can be with somebody else on the community
you know that offline with some friends or. Going to somebody else's place. That's. That's a lot of things as.
Is obviously the jordan got a degree of freedom by haps and of his innocence to have a degree of freedom.
That these guys i don't think is this possible. In the urban environment.
They've learnt to grow up with what are considered good healthy attitudes towards the environment environmental issues
just so much for granted.
Because you don't rubbish things and of course you don't do this and of course you don't do that.
Whereas it had he said we had to learn. Or take on board that they missed just the way it is. And they have got.
I don't know. Some have said what i want to get out there and. Mike a million bucks.
Get rich can go to they thought i was done. Mark mark jordan.
At this stage just a little bit there and just turning to you know i just know i haven't got any for them
and fixed attitudes as to what they'd like to really do with themselves once they finish school.
But i've seen a number of children grow up here and leave. As what i consider a good adult in a lot.
Interesting people. Good attitudes. Do we'll at school. We certainly haven't. Will or.
The people who haven't tried to anyway i suppose dollar for education as well. Not the children here have gone.
All gone to the public school back as well which is a very nice little. Country school.
Now we need to get one hundred pupils for teachers just a very good school it's got an enormous amount of community
input into it from the parents is perhaps the best of both rules. It's for a public education and. It's got enough.
External input. That that. It's possible to schools have parallel input does seem to have a lot of.
Very positive fair unlimber they have things like all cultural. Options.
Which is when parents will come along and one day a week for maybe a month or six weeks.
And take a small group of children in a particular. Anything. Are just.
Bodies to the group of kids making charms out of all forks and spoons and another woman. Did filt miking.
Just things like that and opportunities for kids to learn things like that. A fiver.
Remember the story would be here are all part of that one.
Ask me another question at all while i think we have to put the pause button on.
Five min with a sense of place in the narrow our really feel proud to sign on from the menu that's where i come from.
Years ago i saw him from back as violence between cars. But now i'm from niman just out of newman actually. It was.
It was the paypal. Thing that drew. The drew me here that all the. I was particularly attracted to just the r. D.
Of settling in an area.
Lots of lot want to people you know kids and kin and creating a community where you thought like.
You weren't one of them on already. But the. But that you are one of the establishment. Even though.
It was your own establishment.
I think that's still what is perhaps my strongest feeling about him
and you know especially for being a wife a little bit more drop back in didn't even for a few days
and you drive into town is just so different from anywhere else you know anything new in the him again you there
and there is total ad of derelicts collapsed in front of the hot bread shop that was yes i was wonderful.
Brought up the list of use these check hadn't come in and the usual. Kloster at saw the rind.
And just just all sorts of characters and people in really. Disreputable baggy old thoughts. Wandering along. Yeah.
Just. Just the color. And the nonconformist. Well it's pretty conforming. With the end isn't it.
Really are sadly like that
when the rat pack came to town with with their shredded claw in their dreadlocks to the news of things like oh
wonderful here. I want it visually. On a visual exhorting them and and.
Are like a lock the whole aspect of chinese to walk the fact that there's all these things happening this is perma
culture village already heard kicks off in him and just because it'll mean yet another group of people and more.
In georgia and not a lot of the best but.
I just walked out dynamics of it not being something stagnant that whole lot of all hippies went to die.
But somewhere where a whole lot of new hippies are coming to live as well yeah.
Like saying the young people not just hippies is people. I mean this. There's lots of.
Lots of people that are hippies around applies to the moved in for whatever reasons. Good solid people. Yes will.
Few challenges from them and i think the sewage one of the big challenges that.